i don't think we're in times where
people are inquisitive where they're
curiou they're lazy people are lazy and
they look and they want to be mad all
the time someone's always the enemy you
know they rather they'd rather get upset
and pound and scream
that
then have a conversation so you know
he's also operating at a time when
people have no attention span when all
these mediums are active that edit and
the sound bites and you know it's it's
not it's not a great time for someone
who does have controversial things to
say but really benefits from a long-form
interview which he does because i've
i've watched them and i see how i really
looked and i even i even tried to crop
some and said wow well if i took just
this and this i would have this reaction
but if i hear all of this
i still disagree but it's a very
different reaction than what i would
have had so but it takes effort right
not everyone's gonna sit here and do
what i just did because they don't care
they'd rather just watch 30 seconds be
mad and go on with their day right to
the next thing they can be mad about